green jeanpierre who just asked about
the surge in anti-semitic attacks what
does kjp have to say about it level of
concern right now about the potential
rise of anti-Semitism in light of
everything that's going on in Israel so
a couple of things um look um uh we have
not seen uh any credible uh threats I
know there's been always questions about
uh credible threats uh and so uh just
want to make sure that that's out there
but look uh Muslim and those perceived
uh to be Muslim have endured a
disproportionate uh number of hate
fueled attacks and certainly President
Biden understands that many of our
Muslim Arab AR Arab Americans and
palestino American loved ones and
neighbors are worried about the hate
being directed at their communities well
hold on hold on I the question was what
do you think about all the attacks on
Jews and then Karen Jean's answer is yes
islamophobia is a really big problem